[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be covering
the top eight most powerful offensive
spells in the Harry Potter universe we
aren't going to be covering defensive or
protective spells like sacrificial
protection salvio hexia or the Patronus
charm we're going to be honing in on the
spells that a witch or wizard might use
in an effort to deal maximum damage
comparing spells can sometimes be
difficult particularly in the case of
offensive spells because we haven't
actually seen many of them used against
each other additionally the properties
of individual spells are usually very
unique and if they were all more or less
the same then it would basically negate
the requirement for more spells with all
that in mind
bear with me in this video as I attempt
to rank the top eight most powerful
offensive spells if you agree with my
list great
but I also employ you all to come up
with your own lists and if you come up
with your own then comment it down below
without further ado let's get started
number eight bombarda maxima Bambara
maxima is the most powerful version of
the exploding charm bombarda the primary
function of pommes Potter was to blast
opened sealed doors or to blow bars off
of windows while Bambaataa Maxima
allowed for witches and wizards to do
this on a much more exaggerated scale
unlike the tiny explosions caused by
poor bada boom bada Maxima provoked
large violent explosions capable of
demolishing entire walls
Umbridge notably uses Bambaataa Maxima
in the film's to break into the Room of
Requirement Bambara is often confused
with the blasting curse conferring go
which is used to achieve a similar
outcome causing the targeted object of
the curse to explode though we don't see
Bambaataa used a whole lot in the film's
I think that it would be silly to ignore
its inherent destructive potential it's
a spell that blows things up on a large
scale I think number eight is fair I
should also note that bombarda only
appears in the film's number seven
crucio Cuchillo aka the Cruciatus curse
aka the torture curse is one of the
three unforgivable curses and is widely
regarded as one of the most sinister
spells in the entire Wizarding World it
causes the victim to experience
excruciating pain pain beyond what they
could otherwise possibly conceive the
name comes from the Latin words for pain
and torture and alludes to the adjective
excruciating which is a descriptor of
its effects the Cruciatus curse was
freely used until 1717 when it was named
one of the unforgivable curses known
proponents of the Cruciatus curse
include Bellatrix Lestrange
Barty Crouch jr. and Lord Voldemort it
was most notably used by the strange on
Frank and Alice Longbottom driving them
into complete insanity casting crucio is
set to require a wand and incantation
and its effects are said to vary
depending on the casters desires and
emotions to produce the excruciating
pain implied by the name the caster must
despise the victim and enjoy causing
pain Harry Potter
after crucio was cast on him described
it as feeling like his head was being
split open while having his bones set on
fire while crucial causes immense
suffering it has been expressed that the
spell can't actually kill you it can
only stimulate the pain receptors in the
body and for this reason crucio is not
higher on the list number 6
Sectumsempra snakes very own spell
Sectumsempra we first see Sectumsempra
in the films when Herod used on Malfoy
in half-blood Prince
Sectumsempra is a vicious dark curse
that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts for its target often after being
struck the target will lay there
motionless as they lose blood it is
somewhat of a specialty of Snape's and
is featured in his textbook for advanced
potion making the only known treatment
for Sectumsempra is vulnera sanentur
which was also invented by Snape what's
so dangerous about Sectumsempra is that
it was seemingly easy for Harry to cast
but still nearly killed Draco the first
time that he used it while the
unforgivable curses require intent and
an understanding of the spells to
effectively cast them Sectumsempra seems
doesn't require the same level of intent
or deep understanding but still produces
the same lethal results
Sectumsempra would be higher up on the
list but were actually not fully aware
of just how lethal Sectumsempra is was
Harry's casting on Draco just a fluke
either way I've seen enough of it in
action to place it on the list
number five The Tempest jinx in one
scene in fantastic beasts we see who we
think is Grindelwald locked up in an
incarceration carriage being escorted by
various auras the man locked up in the
carriage is actually a transfigured
Abernathy it is during this scene that
Grindelwald casts The Tempest jinx The
Tempest jinx is an atmospheric jinx that
causes bolts of lightning to emerge from
the clouds striking his targets this is
an incredibly powerful spell and just
another example of Grindelwald elemental
mastery the following excerpt describes
the powerful effects of the spell when
Grindelwald uses it on multiple auras
still driving the carriage Grindelwald
swirls his wand in the air toward the
surrounding storm clouds one by one
folks of lightning strike the broomstick
riders knocking each intern from the sky
while we don't know a lot about this
spell casting it clearly displays
elemental mastery which is the calling
card of a truly powerful witch or wizard
Grindelwald uses it to easily get rid of
multiple auras and if he's summoning
lightning from the sky then I'm willing
to bet that it could do some damage
number 4
Avada Kedavra Avada Kedavra aka the
killing curse is a favorite of many dark
witches and wizards and is one of the
three unforgivable curses perhaps the
worst
varta cadaverous purpose is simple it
costs the victim to instantly die if you
want to kill your victim and this is a
spell to use Lord Voldemort is a known
proponent of the spell which creates a
blindingly intense green bolt of light
right before the victim simply drops
dead there are two theories for how they
died the first claiming that the victims
internal organs cease to function of
being struck and the second claiming the
soul of the victim is magically ripped
from their body the only known counter
spell to Avada Kedavra is
official protection which was most
notably used by Lily Potter who uses the
power of love the name Avada Kedavra
comes from the word abracadabra which
means let the thing be destroyed
Avada Kedavra is used very often in the
books and films most notably by
Voldemort on Harry Potter's parents and
by Snape on Dumbledore though there is
no way to block Avada Kedavra
effectively you can move objects in the
way of the green jet of light that it
produces
Avada Kedavra is powerful but it's
really not that special and I think that
if you want to cause damage on a larger
scale there are some better options
that's why I've placed it at number four
number three
firestorm let me briefly introduce this
one with an excerpt from the book but
then through the darkness fire erupted
crimson and gold a ring of fire that
surrounded the rock so the thean fairy
holding Harry so tightly stumbled and
faulted Dumbledore was on his feet again
pale as any of the surrounding in fairy
but taller than any to the fire dancing
in his eyes his wand was raised like a
torch and from its tip emanated the
flames like a vast lasso encircling them
all with warmth firestorm otherwise
known as lasso of flames is an
incantation that produces a large ring
of fire from the caster's wand when the
caster moves the ring of fire moves with
them which will effectively ward off
anyone trying to hurt them while this
may seem like a defensive spell at first
firestorm also has offensive
capabilities and the caster also
possesses the ability to shoot
individual Jets or paws of flames and
nearby enemies this ability pairs well
with parties tempura's which allows a
gap in the flames for the caster to
safely pass through Dumbledore use this
spell to ward off the masses of in vari
who are guarding the Horcrux even in his
weakened state
this spell proved to be more than enough
to serve its purpose because of this
massively powerful spells ability to
address a large number of enemies I
think that it deserves this placing on
list number two fiend fire let me start
off with an excerpt outlining the
effects of fiend
it was not normal fire crab had used a
curse of which Harry had no knowledge as
they turned a corner
the flames chased them as though they
were alive sentient intent upon killing
them now the fire was mutating forming a
gigantic pack of fiery beasts flaming
serpents chimeras and Dragons rose and
fell and rose again and the detritus of
centuries on which they were feeding was
thrown up in the air into their fanged
mouths tossing high on clawed feet
before being consumed by the inferno
fiend fire is one of the most powerful
spells in Harry Potter period Voldemort
is a known proponent of the spell and he
can be seen using it against Dumbledore
in their epic duel in the Ministry
atrium fiend fire produces enchanted
flames of an enormous scale that
essentially destroy anything in its path
often taking the form of gigantic fiery
beasts fiend fire is extremely advanced
dark magic and is also one of only a few
known ways to destroy a Horcrux number
one protego diabolica here it is the
most powerful offensive spell but wait
isn't protego a defensive spell
traditionally yes but the version of
protego that we see in the crimes of
quinn Dewald vertigo diabolica has clear
offensive capabilities particular
diabolica is potentially the most
powerful spell any of us have witnessed
across all harry potter and fantastic
beasts films it even makes fiend fire
look weak in comparison we first see
Gellert Grindelwald use a protego
diabolica in illis trains mausoleum
protego diabolica is a dark spell that
creates a ring of protective black fire
around the target anyone who's an enemy
of the caster will be instantly
incinerated when they try to enter the
circle in addition to its obvious
defensive capabilities the possibilities
of this Pelt seem endless as we also see
Crenn Dewalt controlling the spell like
a weapon extending tendrils of black
flames towards his enemies with these
tendrils Grindelwald was able to prevent
auras from escaping the mausoleum via
apparition the spell eventually
escalates into what can only be
described as a fiery wind demon similar
to fiend fire it was mentioned that if
the spell hadn't been stopped
by the combined efforts of the
protagonists that would have destroyed
all of Paris a single spell that can
destroy an entire city that definitely
our classes Avada Kedavra and that's it
for this video I hope you enjoyed it
leave your own top eight list down in
the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]